today is World AIDS Day now of course
Charlie Sheen recently made headlines
when he confirmed that he is HIV
positive and we spoke to two celebrity
leaders in the fight against AIDS Kathy
Ireland and Ricki Lake who weighed in on
Charlie's announcement
my heart and our prayers go out to him
for everybody who is dealing with this
it's it's heartbreaking I think it was
incredibly brave of him I just think
it's good to anytime we can raise
awareness and for him to come out and as
he did and you know the fact that he
said that he has been on treatment since
the point of diagnosis you know it he
really it's very hard to transmit the
disease when you're on medication they
are three stars all personally touched
by this disease
all doing everything they can to help
find a cure Kathy's connection was
through her mentor and business partner
de Mille is with Taylor she would go
quietly with no media with no press she
would go in to hospice and she would hug
patients who had just not felt that
human contact and her legacy is love and
life but what many don't know is that
Liz set up a secret underground network
to get experimental HIV drugs to
patients just like the true story in
Dallas buyers club do you mean to tell
me that Elizabeth Taylor essentially set
up a West Coast buyers club talk about
fearless in at her home in Bel Air it
was a it was a safe house and a lot of
the work that she did it was illegal but
she was saving live she said her
business associates pleaded with her
leave this thing alone
she received death threats friends hung
up on her when she asked for help but
something that I love about Elizabeth is
her courage is it true that she actually
even sold her jewelry to fund this
operation yes she would she would sell
jewelry she would
there was transfers of money sometimes
they would be like a paper bag there'd
be money today Kathy who Liz willed her
two precious dogs to continues Liz's
fight was she scared that she would ever
get caught she thought she might but she
wasn't afraid she'd go to jail for it
she wasn't no Elizabeth and fear not in
the same sentence
fearless fearlessness courage and
compassion for people in need that's
what this is really about Ricki Lake
took those words and made them her
mission statement as she and for social
media stars went to a school in Malawi
to film treatment for all the first
documentary launched on Facebook the
ugly cry yeah I do it many times and
these children that have nothing they
are orphaned by AIDS all of their
parents have died from this disease they
have nothing really but the clothes on
their back and they have this
opportunity to be educated and yet they
are so filled with joy and hope I really
really take a huge responsibility for
being able to do some good and to help
these people that are our neighbors yes
there across the world but they're there
they're just like us